قال وزير الخارجيه الامريكي انطوني بلينكن
انه لا يمكن لاي شخص ان يتخيل ما مر به
مدير مكتب الجزيره في غزه وائل الدحدوح
واضاف بلينكن في مقابله مع شبكه ام بي سي
ان واشنطن تضغط باستمرار على اسرائيل
لتجنب سقوط ضحايا مدنيين على حد
قوله سالت الوزير بلينكن عن العدد الهائل
للقتلى في غزه بما في ذلك القتل الماساوي
للابن الاكبر لمدير مكتب الجزيره الذي فقد
اثنين من اولاده زوجته وحفيده فهل اثرت
هذا الامر مع الحكومه في اسرائيل لان
كثيرين يعتقدون ان هذه عمليات قتل متعمده
لعائله مدير مكتب
الجزيره لا اعتقد انه يمكن لاي منا ان
يتخيل ما مر به هذا الرجل وعندما يتعلق
الامر بالرجال والنساء والاطفال
الفلسطينيين او عندما يتعلق بالصحفيين فقد
حدثنا وضغطنا على الاسرائيليين باستمرار
بما في ذلك اليوم لبذل كل ما في وسعهم
لتجنب سقوط ضحايا
مدنيين